C'est quand même dingue le nombre d'abonnés qu'elle a, c'est pas mérité !
Nan mais m'en parle pas, ça me saoule à chaque fois.
Oh ma chérie regarde les fleurs, elles sont trop belles.
Oh grave vas-y viens, on fait un selfie.
On va prendre une p'tite fleur.
Ah oui t'as raison.
Tiens.
Trop bien
*crache la fleur*
Putain
#Summer #Flowers
Bon alors ici tu vas voir, c'est super. En fait leur spécialité, c'est de faire des dessins dans le café.
Oh le latte art, j'adore ça.
Je sais, c'est pour ça que je t'emmène là.
*Serveur* Le Cappuccino ... Le Grand Crème *Serveur*
Merci
Ahhhhh trop beau !
T'es contente ?
C'est trop beau
Moi aussi je vais prendre une petite photo.
T'avais pris le euh... le Cappuccino toi ?
Oui
Ils se sont trompés.
Ah oui.
Hop là
Voilà
Bah non, tu vas pas poster cette photo, c'est pas ton café.
Bah oui non...
Bah oui
Alors, photo.
Oh c'est trop beau ça !
Faut que je lui dise
Ma chérie, t'as photo elle est trop b...
J'essaye d'en faire une deuxième.
Tu veux de l'aide ?
S'il te plait
J'arrive
J'ai mal !
Vas-y lâche, lâche
- Merci
- vas y lâche
- je peux pas
- lâche, lâche,
- Oh purée *soulagement*
- Hop là c'est bon
ENCORE !
Mais c'est pas possible ça, c'est la cinquième qui est toute noire, c'est nul ton truc là.
Arrête, je comprends pas, d'accord ?
Les filles sur insta quand elles le font, elles ça marche.
Bah c'est peut-être toi qui appuie mal, vas-y refait une dernière fois.
- Oh arrête de me crier dessus
- Oh ça va ça va ça va
ENCORE !!!
Putain mais c'est nul ton truc
Oh là là mais ce qu'il est mignon.
Je l'ai appelé Sweetie.
Sweetie ohhhh... c'est chou
Mais, t'es pas allergique aux chiens toi ?
Moi ?
N.. na.. nan, de mémoire nan...
Alice, tu as pris un chiot pour avoir plus de likes sur insta ?!
Mais pas du tout, tu es folle ou quoi ?
Vas-y prend le 2 secondes, faut que je prenne mes antihistaminique
Regarde la caméra
Ehh tu prends pas en photo mes likes !!! ...
Euh mon chiot j'veux d...
Euh Sweetie hein...
*éternuement*
Oh, t'est quand-même très allergique, hein?
Tu le veux ?
Nan nan nan en fait nan
Je... attend
Heureusement que ça fait des likes
Eh le chouchou...
Vas-y, prends la photo
Ah mais non, mais j'ai pas mon téléphone, tu m'as dit que tu prenais le tiens
Mais nan mais pas du tout, le mien il est entrain de charger
*Soupir* Putain
- Aïe
- Aïe, ahhh, ça tire ça tire
- On y va en même temps
- Ok
On se lève quand je dis qu'on se lève
- Vas-y
- On se lève allez
Ok voilà
Putain AÏÏÏÏÏÏÏÏE
Aïe, on va où ?
On va à gauche euh
Ta gauche ou ma gauche ?
- Mais c'est la même Alice
- Ah oui c'est vrai, c'est la même gauche
Allez, petits pas, petits pas
*Pleurs*
Le connard il est partit avec sa Fiat
team rose...
Quel Connard !
Je suis désolé mon chat
Putain, je veux plus entendre parler, qu'il m'en parles plus, il existe plus
C'est simple j'ai supprimé toutes ses photos sur mon insta, Voila Pouf !
T'as laissé une photo quand même...
*Bruit Strident*
T'as pas supprimé
A bon ?
Nan.
Bah vas-y supprime la, je suis avec toi
Nan, mais ça doit être une erreur, j'ai fais ça vite tu sais
Mais enfin c'est ridicule, je suis la, supprime la !
Mais c'est peut-être une qui passait comme ça
Tu veux pas la supprimer car c'est celle qui a le plus de likes sur ton Insta ?
*Bruit Strident*
Non...
C'était un oubli
Et bah supprime la
A oui il y a le...
Elle est la ouais
*Soupir* *souffle*
Ca fait mal hein ?
Oui ça fait mal oui...
Tu parles de la rupture ?
Oui bien sûr que je parle de la rupture
T'as plus Sweetie ?
Quoi ?
Sweetie ?
C'est quoi ça Swee...?
Ah oui mon chiot, ah non non je l'ai rendu nan
Ca faisait pas assez de likes ?
Mais n'importe quoi toi bêta, mais nan, c'est parce que je suis allergique tu vois bien !
On va où la ?
A une animalerie, je vais prendre un chat
Mais Alice, T'es aussi allergique aux chats !
Mais, laisse-moi perçer sur Insta
T'as pas aimé ma tenue d'hier ?
Bah si !
Ton petit Crop en lin avec t'as petite veste
Pourtant sur ma story quand j'ai demandé :
"Est-ce que vous validez ma tenue du jour ?"
T'as répondu non
*Bruit Strident*
On peut savoir qui a voté sur Instagram
Selon les statistiques, tu glisse vers le haut
Ah bon ?
Ah mais en fait ça va me permettre de savoir qui à voter "bof" à mon maquillage du jour ?
J'ai mis un temps f... oohh
Et voilà comment on fait une très belle couronne de fleurs
A putain attends, Y'a une guêpe !
Non, non, Zoé on est en live
Mais je m'en bats les couilles de ton live, Ok ?
Pourquoi elle m'attaque la ? Arrête !
C'est la couronne de fleurs, Zoé !
Mais pourquoi t'en a pas pris en plastique ?
Mais c'est pas bio !
Mais je m'en bats les couilles de ton bio, t'as pas compris !
Va-t'en guêpe de merde, Sale pute de guêpe !
Ok, les filles
(Zoé) -Regarde-moi bien
Krav-maga!!!
-A bientôt sur un prochain live !
-Qu'est ce que tu v'as m'faire !
Animal de Satan !!!
Oh les filles c'est magnifique, venez on prend un selfie ?
OH OUAIS, oh ouais obligé, allez !
Cheese
*Rires*
Alice, tu fais encore un placement de produit là ?
*Insatisfaction*
C'est pas si bien payé hein ?
Non, non, non !
-J't'avais dit que tu pouvais pas lui faire confiance
Mais j'ai un code promo si vous voulez
Ouais maintenant mets les passeports !
Ouais, là?
Ouais non plus bas, plus bas, plus bas
-Ouais !  -Là ?
Voilà
Maintenant va t'en va t'en va t'en
Vite ouste !
*Photo*
Voilà
Maintenant pendant 4 jours
On poste des photos de plages qu'on trouve sur internet
Et les gens ne sauront pas que c'est pas nos jambes
Ah ouais t'es maline
On va aux Seychelles
Génial !
Bon, allez vas y viens on sort
Ben non on va pas sortir
Si les gens nous reconnaissent
Ils savent qu'on est pas là-bas !
Personne nous a jamais reconnues Alice !
Ouais bah ça peut arriver (hein !)
On sort pas pendant 4 jours
Ouais plus la
Comme ça voila !
Ça fera une super belle photo
Ils sont où tes pieds ?
Ils sont là, tu les vois où pas ?
Non essaie de l'autre coté plutôt
*Musique sensuel*
*R.I.P l'ordi*
*Bruit des bulles*
*Photo*
Je...
Tu l'as ?
Non